[Music]
congratulations Thanks official yeah it
is five weeks now yeah how was the
wedding
it was perfect it was Hanna was happy
and that was my number one priority
and so it worked out my family was there
I got to spend time with people haven't
gotten to see in a while and celebrate a
special time in my life and in my wife's
life so and our family's life so it was
a really really a great moment so what
is the one thing that you'll really
remember from that day that you weren't
necessarily expecting there are emotions
that you can't really plan for that that
just sort of sneak up and just almost
knock you off your feet like when you're
standing there and they don't come in
the big moments I feel like it's just
little things like seeing your your mom
sitting beside your grandmother who
needs to help get enough to walk down
the aisle and like her little brother is
is uh is escorting my grandmother down
the islands just to see our families
come together in that way it was really
special for me so yeah
and how is newlywed life did you guys go
into honeymoon what have you been doing
these last couple weeks yeah we went
down to Puerto Rico and hung out for a
little wild in Hawaii she lived in
Hawaii for a while and we both loved the
Big Island out there so we hung out for
about a week there just had a good time
I remember I saw you out there but you
were going to visitors that's right
that's right yeah I think last summer I
went out there about seven times in
about three months trying to talk her
into coming back and a seventh trip I
got I convinced her persistence worked
it did fortunately yeah what's it been
like for you to share these moments with
her I'm bringing her into your world
it's been awesome um you know she has
her own life and her own ambitions and
her own dreams and then things were
important to her but um and I want to
support those as much as she has
supported me in my aspirations and what
we've got going on here in Nashville and
all that so I think it's been a little
outside of this first few weeks of
marriage so our for sure but um we'll
get to this fall get to do a lot of
other
things besides just drag her around to
the shows and works out the absolute but
she's having fun
you
you